大家好 我是來自蠻隱密算的吳俞朵
今天帶來數據要素流通木刻系列
主題是 密胎大數據安全方案與實踐
主要內容分為四部分
從背景與挑戰 系統架構設計
和核心安全能力和典型應用場景
來解析密胎大數據引擎的方案
首先介紹密胎大數據的背景與挑戰
數據20條在2022年發布以來
對於數據要素流通的需求及待解決
如何讓數據安全的流通
最大化數據的價值成為了數據要素市場化的關鍵
與此同時 在向政務 金融 醫療等領域的數據
呈現了大規模的續盟發展
在進行大數據的處理時間過程中
也暴露出了很多風險
向數據在存儲 流通 計算過程中的泄漏問題
數據出獄後的有效管控
對於數據的使用目的 使用方式
使用次數 使用時間等吸力度的控制
也是數據提供方所需要的重要能力
此外 像NPC 同胎加密等方案
沒有達到對大規模數據計算性能的需求
那麼如何兼顧數據規模 安全保障
計算性能三個方面是重中之重
在其中面臨著三個主要的安全問題
第一是在保證性能的前提下
保護數據在存儲 傳輸
計算過程中的機密性
防止越權數據訪問
運為管理人員盜取數據
第二是在數據離開
數據持有方的控制欲後
如何保證仍然能夠得到
持有方的有效全線控制
在數據計算 流出等關鍵的流程上
都需要遵從提供方的全線約束
防止全線越過 偽造或篡改
第三是如何對數據實施
細力度的動態策略配置
在數據內容使用場景 執行的算法
執行計算的環境 數據使用的次數
數據訪問的時間等方面
支持可擴展的動態的
全線配置與管理
那麼基於上述的背景與挑戰
接下來介紹
密泰大數據引擎的架構設計方案
以及如何解決了
大規模數據計算場景的安全問題
密泰大數據引擎是
基於可信執行環境構建
里程通過硬件可信跟作為可信基礎
通過遠程證明服務
對可信應用身份進行註冊 認證和管理
可信廟管理服務通過雙線遠程認證
給可信應用提供了廟管理的能力
在此基礎上構建了
密泰大數據的核心計算引擎
計算引擎分為兩類
分別是支持大規模數據的
理線計算引擎
是通過SPAC實現的
另一類是支持
實施計算的在線計算引擎
是通過密泰數據庫實現的
除了計算引擎之外
還有管控相關的服務
任務管理服務
負責理線計算任務的調度
和狀態管理等
遠數據管理服務對不同類型
不同來源的各類遠數據
進行統一管理
其中還包括策略管理
血源管理等能力
服務在如計算任務的執行
數據查看
數據導出等
數據的這種訪問節點
會進行訪問控制
建築的流程中還會包括
對請求方的身份認證
捲線判定
以及與數據訪問請求相關的
附加操作
比如數據密要的獲取
存出訪問憑證的獲取等等
身份認證服務
是負責用戶身份註冊
認證的能力
基於上述的能力提供了
統一的對外接口支持
數據的管理全線的管理
任務的管理等功能
接下來
我們從控制計算
數據三個平面展開
從數據的流通角度來看
各個功能組件之間的關係
首先在控制平面
研發管理平台作為
整體的入口
給用戶提供了數據管理
任務管理等一個圖形界面
可以支持用戶編寫
計算邏輯發起計算任務等等
在數據流入的過程中
數據加密後
通過數據流入的組件
流入到數據存儲中
數據在流入之前
在數據提供方域內
會完成數據的封裝
封裝後的形式我們稱之為
密碳數據膠囊
其中包括遠數據密緣數據
加密的數據密要
使用策略的
數據膠囊的細節
會在後面展開描述
數據在完成流入之後
會通過平台發起
理線或在線任務
首先來看理線任務
理線任務通過
任務管理服務解析之後
通過基於KBIAS的
任務調度機制
將任務按需下發到
civilus spark集群
或者拉起經典模式的 spark集群
這裡我們對於
理線任務支持了兩種不同的模式
那麼其中civilus spark
是使用默認的
資源配置和常駐化的集群
可以執行快速的計算
這種模式能夠
避免由於資源競爭
或者等待帶來的任務耗時問題
經典模式能夠
支持自定義的資源配置
並單獨拉起 spark集群
滿足用戶的一些定制化需求
那麼
在線任務是
不通過任務管理的模塊的
而是直接請求到
mita數據庫的引擎裡面
spark引擎和mita數據庫
在執行任務的過程中
在執行數據iO操作之前
會被內置的
健全模塊或組件攔截
對目標訪問的數據對象
進行解析
發起健全請求到
健全引擎當中
健全引擎會印證
請求的數據
以及一些上下文信息
向環境信息 任務信息等等
來判斷是否滿足
預定義的策略
如果滿足的話
就會返回數據訪問的憑證
數據加密的密要
用來支持後續的計算
那麼如果健全失敗
計算引擎就無法
讀取加密的數據
也獲取不到數據的密要
實現了對衛壽權數據訪問的
有效攔截
其中數據密要
也是以密文的形式存儲的
數據密要的加密密要
我們稱之為K1K
是由健全引擎管理
而且是只有健全引擎
這個可行應用
才能夠獲取可行密要
管理服務中對應的密要
其他任何的應用
是沒有辦法
偽造他的身份去獲取這個密要的
實現了對數據密要的安全管控
在健全的過程中
還會依賴數據管理中的
遠數據
數據血源
數據策略等
為健全的流程
提供了輔助信息
此外
在離線引擎和在線引擎之間
還支持這個數據存儲
格式的統計
用來支持同一份數據
在不同場景中的
不同計算需求
下面來看
密泰離線計算引擎的具體實現邏輯
Spark集群的啟動
是依賴基於KBIAS的
任務調度能力
實現了資源的動態感知和分配
Spark集群中的
Driver和Executor節點
都會被分別拉起
Spark的各個節點啟動之後
都會通過遠程認證服務
完成可信節點的啟動認證
各個節點
通過一個共享的SASAID
向可信密藥管理服務
通過雙向的身份認證
能夠獲取
當前所屬Spark集群共享的密藥
那麼這個密藥
是用於這個Spark節點之間的
可信RPC通道的構建
像密藥等
這種敏感的信息
在同步的時候
就會受到加密的保護
那麼由於計算節點本身
是屬於可信環境的
節點之間有基於可信身份的
密密認證
數據在計算節點外部的時候
是密門存儲的
那麼就有效的保證了
數據在計算過程中
不會被院委人員和管理人員
獲取到數據名吻
密胎再現計算
依賴於密胎數據庫
能夠為用戶提供交互時的查詢
也就是即時響應和
獲取結果的能力
為了實現有效的
吸力度的全線管控
用了一個密胎數據庫的網關
通過網關實現了幾類能力
其中包括身份認證
SEQ解析和重寫
全線某塊
數據的加緊密密某塊
其中用戶身份認證
保證數據發起的操作
和任務的信息是可信的
SEQ的解析
是用於獲取訪問的數據對象
進行全線教驗
數據的加緊密密某塊
或在完成健全之後
對SEQ與據中的列值
查詢結果中的值
進行加緊密的操作
SEQ請求中的列值
會以加密的形式傳入
在列值完成解密之後
需要通過SEQ重寫
再將請求發送到密胎數據庫當中
密胎數據庫
網關與密胎數據庫都是可信應用
在通過GDBC訪問
密胎數據庫的時候
可信廟管理服務
會為這兩個應用
用於SSL的私藥和證書
雙方之間
能夠實現基於可信身份認證的
加密通信
基於上述的架構和流程介紹
下面對密胎數據引擎的
核心安全能力進行解析
核心安全能力主要分為
三部分
分別為原始數據不出譽
數據可用不可見
數據可控可計量
原始數據不出譽的
具體實現是
數據會以密穩的方式進行流通
沒有被授權的用戶
是無法獲得數據明文的
能夠有效的阻止數據的洩漏
數據可用不可見
指的是數據在存儲
計算
傳輸的過程當中
都以加密的形式出現
是不可見的狀態
即使是院員管理人員
也無法獲取到數據的明文
加密文上可以執行的
算字和明文上是等效的
支持了對於數據的
端案化分析和處理
可以最大化的發揮數據的價值
數據可控可計量
包括數據快遇後的
有效全線管控
動態的細力度的策略配置
以及過程的存證與審計
用於支持事後的問題溯源
那麼我們首先介紹
原始數據不出譽
數據可用不可見的
實現要點
數據在提供方策
基於本地產生的數據密藥
加密原始數據
然後使用平台公藥
加密本地產生的數據密藥
並生成對應的原數據策略
並使用用戶的私藥
對上述內容進行簽名
保證數據
與提供方之間的持有關係
可嚴重
最終封裝得到的
加密數據密藥
加密數據
帶簽名的策略和原數據
共同組成了
密探數據膠囊
並以膠囊的形式
進行數據快語傳輸操作
在密探大數據引擎中
執行計算任務時
會對上述簽名
等可交易的內容進行驗證
而後基於全線策略的決策
獲取解密的數據密藥
在引擎中使用數據密藥
解密數據後
在實施具體的計算邏輯
計算後產生的結果
仍然是加密形式的
由引擎
生成新的數據密藥來加密結果
數據使用方在請求
獲取結果時
通過全線教驗後
結果到數據密藥
會通過使用方的公藥
加密後返回
數據使用方在本地
獲取結果密文
並執行解密
整個流程中
數據在流入
流出計算的環節
都是密探的形式
計算時在可信空間中
以明文的形式出現
並執行計算
所以能夠支持
與明文等效的算子能力
上述流程中
密探數據交能
是數據要素流通中的
統一封裝形式
其中包括了元數據
裡面有數據標識
數據提供方等等
以及提供方的見面信息
用來保證元數據的
完整性和真實性
此外還包括
數據提供方創建的密藥
是通過平臺的密藥加密的
以及加密的數據
數據的學員關係
數據關聯的權限
控制策略等
策略中也帶有
持有方的簽名
用來保證策略
是合法有效的
另外還有數據的
持有權證明
這個證明是為了
對這個數據標識
數據內容
與持有方主體之間的
對應關係的
正確性的印證
那麼我們通過
這樣的密探數據
交能的形式化結構
能夠有效保證
數據是被提供方
合法持有的
受到提供方
創建的策略約束
而且數據
只有在引擎中
經過健全之後
才能夠進行解密
有效的保證了
數據離開
數據持有者的
控制域之後
仍然能夠有效的
控制數據的使用情況
不被竊取
和非預期的使用
那麼對於
理線在線引擎
計算過程中的
密探化
我們在架構介紹的時候
也提到過了
就是基於
可信能力
運行在可信的
隔離環境當中
而且節挺之間
也是通過基於
可信應用身份的
密藥或者證書等等
進行認證
和通道加密
對於可控可計量的保證
主要是圍繞著
快與全線管控展開
首先
要保證提供方的
全線策略
在引擎內部
能夠有效的實施
沒有月權
或非預期的操作出現
其次
要支持細力度的
策略配置
在使用內容
使用場景
使用方式
使用時間
使用次數等等
進行多維度的管控
另外
在出現
非預期的使用
或者其他問題的時候
也可以通過
使用過程的日治存證
再事後進行
審計和溯源
在數據20條中提出
數據要溯流通中
圍繞數據
有三位權限
分別是數據持有權
數據加工使用權
數據經營權
數據持有權指的是
主體持有合法
獲取的數據的權利
是為了防範他人
違規獲取
篡改
洩漏
或者破壞
持有權人數據的
數據加工使用權
是指
能夠支持
通過加工
聚合
分析等方式
對數據進行處理
生成有價值的
衍生數據
數據經營權
為數據的數據經營
提供了
權限基礎
是指可以通過
轉讓
許可等方式
對外提供數據的權利
持有數據的一方
天然具有持有權
持有權意味著
具有最大的權限
可以直接行使
進營權和加工使用權
數據加工使用方
能夠按照
權限規則
受控的訪問數據
而持有數據
經營權的參與方
是只能進行授權的
沒有辦法
直接訪問數據
這三類權限的
管控範圍
包括數據資源
數據產品
相關的實體
比如原始數據
衍生數據
數據服務等等
都包括在內
數據要素流通中的
快遇管控能力
也是圍繞這三權展開的
快遇權限管控的核心
是要保證權限策略
能夠真實有效的實施
需要通過各種技術
手段共同來實現
那麼基於這樣的目標
提出了對應的
技術要求
其中包括數據傳輸
存儲計算過程中的
機密性完整性保證
各類標識和主體之間的關係
不能被篡改
授權規則不能被偽造
只有權力人才能夠
進行創建變更能操作
健全的過程
要保證正確實施
且無法被繞過
另外還需要對
關鍵的數據訪問節點
進行日治存證
方便事後審計
在密胎數據交往的設計當中
保證了數據以交囊形式
在各個流程中的
機密性和完整性
保證了交囊中的
數據內容
數據持有方
密胃之間的對應關係中
策略的簽名
能夠保證
其無法被偽造或篡改
在前面介紹的
理線在線引擎的
計算流程中
健全流程
也基於可信底座
和數據的加密機制
實現了不可繞過的能力
再結合使用過程中的
日治存證
整體完成了
跨域管控的技術要求
圖裡展示的是
理線在線計算的
健全過程
理線引擎中
通過健全的模塊或組件
實現了對數據
訪問操作的有效攔截
其中的核心能力包括
通過對計算任務
請求的解析
或許到請求的
數據對象和具體內容
附加當前的
任務相關信息等的
形成健全請求
而後與健全引擎之間
通過雙線的引程認證
實現全線的教驗
和數據密要存出
訪問憑證的獲取
健全引擎對計算引擎的
可信身份憑證認證之後
會通過這個可信
應用的公要
將密要憑證等的
名單信息
通過這個公要加密返回
同樣也會形成
一個可信的加密通道
健全過程中
會通過策略規則
運行時的上下文
數據的屬性
數據學員等等
作為輔助的信息
最終作出策略判斷的結果
密要和憑證
都是通過
引擎的平台公要加密的
是由健全引擎創建
且只有健全引擎
才能夠獲取
這樣保證數據密要
也是全流成密態的
只有健全成功之後
才能夠在
計算引擎的
可信執行環境中
用於數據的解密
下面通過一個
典型的應用場景舉例
密態大數據引擎的
具體使用方式
在醫保特別是
商業保險的
理賠環節中
通常要結合
醫保信息平台
和保險公司的數據
並基於一定的
理算規則
判斷是否進行
培復和培復的
結合計算
但是醫保信息平台
中有大量的
敏感數據
無法直接
向支付平台
或保險公司透出
而且其中的歷史數據
新增數據規模比較大
在這種場景下
就可以使用密態
大數據計算引擎
達到數據可容不可見
且受控反問的效果
這個場景中的煉路
包括就醫患者
到醫藥的
這個機構進行就診
形成了新的
就診記錄
那麼這個記錄
會匯總到
醫保信息平台
醫保信息平台中
有大量的
歷史的
和新增的
醫保相關的信息
那麼這些信息
會定期以
州計劃的形式
統佈到
密態計算引擎當中
數據流入到引擎中
也是以
我們前面介紹過的
密態數據交囊的形式
而且會配置
有相應的訪問策略
數據流入之後
可以在SPAC中
進行一些
數據融合
數據分析的計算
那麼為了支持
在線的
實施理算
需要定期
將以
理線數據
形式存儲的
以保相關的數據
統佈到
密態數據庫當中
那麼在
就醫之後的
支付環節
結合保險公司的
保單信息
在密態計算引擎當中
可以通過
一個具有
預定義
理算邏輯的
在線服務
調用
密態在線計算引擎
就能夠
拿到理賠結果
那麼在這個場景中
即包含了
醫保信息的
周期理線同步
又包括了
在線查詢
能夠支持
交由廣泛的
醫療相關的場景
這次課程的
主要內容介紹完畢
下面進行
檢要的總結
本次的課程
總結來說
就是
密態大數據引擎
為了保證
大規模數據
安全流通
且高效計算的
能力
通過可信執行
環境
全流成密態計算
與動態全線管控的技術
加上
密態數據交囊
這樣的安全載體
實現了
原始數據不出獄
數據可用不可見
數據可控可計量
三重防護避環
為數據要速安全流通
提供了有效的路徑
那麼本次的介紹
就到這裡了
謝謝大家